Voiceover:Let's think
about another scenario
involving ratios.
In this case, let's think about the ratio
of the number of apples.
Number of apples to ...
Instead of taking the ratio of the number
of apples to the number of oranges,
let's take the number of apples to the
number of fruit.
The number of fruit
that we have over here.
And I encourage you to pause the video
and think about that on your own.
Well, how many total apples do we have?
We have 2, 4, 6, 8 apples.
So we're going to have 8 apples.
And then how much total fruit do we have?
Well we have 8 apples and we have
3, 6, 9, 12 oranges.
So our total fruit is 8 plus 12.
We have 20 pieces of fruit.
So this ratio is going to be 8 to ...
8 to 20.
Or, if we want to write
this in a more reduced form,
we can divide both of these by 4.
4 is their greatest common divisor.
And so this is the same thing as a ratio.
8 divided by 4 is 2 and
20 divided by 4 is 5.
So 2 to 5.
Now, does this make sense?
Well, if we divide ...
If we divide everything into groups of 4.
So ...
Or if we divide into 4
groups, I should say.
So 1 group, 2 groups,
3 groups, and 4 groups.
That's the largest number of groups
that we can divide these into
so that we don't have to cut up the apples
or the oranges.
We see that in each
group, for every 2 apples
we have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 pieces of fruit.
For every 2 apples we
have 5 pieces of fruit.
This is actually a good opportunity for us
to introduce another
way of representing ...
Another way of representing
ratios, and that's
using fraction notation.
So we could also represent this ratio as
2 over 5.
As the fraction 2 over 5.
Whenever we put it in
the fraction it's very
important to recognize
what this represents.
This is telling us the fraction of fruit
that are apples.
So we could say 2/5 of the fruit ...
Of the fruit ...
Of the number of fruit,
I guess I could say.
Of number of fruit ...
Of fruit is equal to the number of apples.
Right, I'm just going to say 2/5 of fruit
if we're just speaking
in more typical terms.
2/5 of fruit are apples.
Are, are apples.
So, once again, this is introducing
another way of representing ratios.
We could say that the
ratio of apples to fruit,
once again, it could be 2 to 5 like that.
It could be 2, instead of putting
this little colon there we could literally
write out the word to.
2 to 5.
Or we could say it's
2/5, the fraction 2/5,
which would sometimes be read as 2 to 5.
This is also, when it's written this way,
you could also read that as a ratio,
depending on the context.
In a sentence like this
I would read this as
2/5 of the fruit are apples.